hello and welcome to Android design in
action my name is Roman Nurik with me
here today is hi guys Adam Koch and over
in London hi Nick butcher
so today unlike most days on the show
most Tuesdays on the show we're not
actually going to be talking about
redesigns so for those of you you know
who have never seen this show we usually
take a look at apps that have been
nominated usually the developer
nominates themselves and take a look at
how we can reimagine some of the screens
in those apps to fit better with you
know Android styling and just be you
know kind of a better experience for
users overall and then we take that and
we pass it off to developers and you
know see if they like it and if they do
then sometimes they make the changes and
sometimes they don't and for those of
you you know who who have been watching
basically developers can come back on
Thursday and let us know what they think
of the show and that's the developer
Strikes Back where developers strike
back show this we cover we're not doing
any of that because of the massive
technical failures that plagued the guys
in Mountain View for the Friday app
clinic we've decided to take a slightly
different approach to the shows or to
this episode today so today we're going
to be talking about responsive design so
let's jump into what responsive design
is now for several people is the first
time they're hearing of the concept of
responsive design and Ethan Marcotte and
saris and if I'm mispronouncing your
name Ethan Marcotte coined the term a
few years ago in a in an article that
talked about responsive web design and
basically you can see from the quote
here this is from the article it's
really about taking a website and making
sure that it scales across any medium be
it you know phone tablet browser at
different you know screen sizes and you
know pretty much any other device type
so taking a single layout or a single a
piece of content and making sure that
scales according to its medium so
respond that's responsive web design in
a super small nutshell so you know
responsive
design responsive web design applies to
mobile apps as well and so today we're
going to be talking about responsive
design and how it applies to Android
devices before you jump in
Adam Nick any comments any thoughts yeah
well as you were saying we're focusing
on responsive design because this week
we're having a big big focus on tablets
we just launched some some quality
guidelines on how to make a high quality
tablet application and for me having an
application which scales well on the
huge variety of devices that is the
Android landscape is you know a big big
part of that quality so I think this is
a really important topic and one quick
thing I wanted to mention was I really
believe if you sort of think about these
these are responsive web design or
responsive Android development from the
beginning of your development cycle when
building Android apps it can help you
get that tablet app or like create
designs that just really make it easier
to to suit all the different screens out
there so rather than just a designer
phone from the ground up if you just
think about all these things from the
beginning it really helps and Before we
jump in again just to talk a little bit
about the format we're not really going
to be talking about development best
practices we do have several training
sessions on developer.android.com on how
to actually implement these concepts but
we will do is we will look into existing
apps that are out there and see how they
treat or how they implement these
responsive designs how they kind of
scale fluidly across the different
device types so let's jump in first
we're going to take a look at calendar
so this is the built-in calendar
application that comes with many devices
like the Galaxy Nexus the Nexus 7 the
Motorola Xoom and this is an example of
the of the screen that lets you create a
new calendar entry so on the phone here
you see that and I'm gonna go she's zoom
in for a second on the phone you see
that you know you have kind of a done
cancel bar at the top which is basically
replacing the action bar
and you know the different entry fields
like the calendar event title the the
date time things like that pretty
typical stuff and then on the Nexus 7
you'll see that it's switched over into
a kind of like a multi-column layout
where on the Left column you have the
labels of the different text entry
fields and on the right you have the
fields themselves and then on the on the
tablet on the 10-inch tablet in
landscape I'm going to zoom in here
sorry about that you'll notice that it's
basically the same screen as the screen
and portrait except it has wider margins
so basically they've decided that you
know let's make sure that the the
content D the text fields never go past
you know a pretty common number you know
around 45 to 75 characters let's make
sure that you can never see more than
that all at once so that the line
lengths aren't too long
so to fit that constraint
let's introduce margins along the sides
so that's an energy stand a nutshell
what what the calendar calendar apps
create event screen looks like guys any
thoughts on on other things that they've
done really well here to make sure that
this is responsive I probably just like
to call out as well we talked a lot on
this show about Holly about the visual
language of Android the holo visual
theme and that it has its own certain
flat look and feel and I just want to
call out why that's you know it's not an
accident that that kind of design scheme
was chosen for Android and I think this
set of screens here really demonstrates
how holo helps you to create a user
interface which scales nicely by using
kind of typography and spacing
appropriately to give your application
structure which you can clearly see in
these three screens that there isn't a
lot of chrome and subdividing boxes and
so on with text boxes and so on
it really is the content which defines
the structure of the page and that
really really helps it to scale either
haven't got lots and lots and lots of
different you know bitmap assets or
graphical assets or gradients all over
the place which may look strange when
scaled up and wouldn't really help you
out
so I think this is one of my major
takeaways from looking at the calendar
application is that how hollow really
really helps out this up to scale across
these screen sizes yeah and one quick
point from me if you look at the white
space on the on the margins let's see if
we zoom in here so you can see on the
phone you've got some white space on the
left and right and then if you go up to
the Nexus 7 you'll see there's a
slightly more white space and then if
you go across to the landscape zoom
you'll see they've actually got more
white space here that sort of makes it
makes everything you know fill out fill
out the larger screen size there it's
important to know that when you're you
know creating or defining these margins
that you still stick to a grid and as
you can see in our design guide under
the metrics and grids section we have
this concept of a 16 Dib grid and a 48dp
rhythm so you know using increments of
16 dips so like you know 32 dip or 48 or
64 that can kind of still introduce
structure into your layouts without kind
of constraining you to just using you
know very small margins so so 32 dips 48
dips that's great kind of to use for
larger devices such as tablets yeah so a
naive implementation that this kind of
screen might have just stretched the
input fields all the way across which
would look pretty ungainly on the
10-inch so I think it's you know
approaching your screen design when
you're when you're designing app and if
you see something which is like fill
parent and thinking about hey how that's
going to is that going to look on a much
wider display like a 10-inch in
landscape for example and bearing in
mind where you might want to start
introducing these margin points yeah all
right so let's move on to the next app
so this will be the first third-party
app that we look at and this is pattern
Nick you want to talk a little bit about
pattern sure so a pattern is a great
little app for finding wallpapers for
your device if by a UK developer called
Lucas who works for Mozilla and I think
they've done a great job of really
making the content adapt luckily for
them they have almost the dream
application for this kind of scenario
where the
the content the patterned wallpapers
have no kind of concept of aspect ratio
or anything like that they actually kind
of tile so that it works really well
that they can change different aspect
ratios which might not be the cases for
maps but and as you can see in in the
free screens we're showing here on the
phone they relying on on free taps to go
through the free major like views of the
data and but when they get you up beyond
a certain point and have more space they
actually break that out away from the
tab navigation into having this sidebar
which I think works really well rather
than just stretching the content to be
overly wide it actually gives you easier
and navigation as well as surfacing more
information so you can see there on the
Nexus 7 for example it surfaces recent
searches so it's kind of one tap away
rather than having to tap into the
search field and then get shown the
recent history it might prompt you to
click on a recent search which is really
great and the other thing if you look at
the difference between say the phone and
the seven-inch tablet is they've
actually hinted the text size and
padding's to be slightly larger to just
feel more comfortable at that certain
size and and then the second sorry it
looks like on a tablet they have just a
slightly wider margin I don't know if
it's an increment of 16 dips like we
talked about but it's definitely
noticeably larger to the left and to the
right of the patterns yeah and then just
lastly I can say when you step up from
the 7 to the 10-inch and have even more
space available they break out into this
kind of grid view where they show you
more more potential wallpapers on screen
at once so it's kind of reimagining the
the content like show it a
representation of the contents it's the
same content but laid out in a
completely different way to just make
much better use of the space yeah I
think I just want to comment one on one
missed opportunity and this is very
minor but if you look at the handsets
version in landscape we don't have a
screen shot here but they also Lucas
also uses a single column for the
patterns so since he's already got
multi-column implemented it seems like
it would be fairly trivial to switch
that over to a
two-column like a two-column layout in
landscape that might work really well
okay so let's move on to the next app
once you guys have any more comments oh
just one question I haven't actually
used this app that much but what's under
the u tab in for the handset version I
mean roaming on Nikki um Nikki I
actually don't remember myself I think
it was I think it was a both favorites I
think it was favorites and something
else but it was a combination of either
one so so I guess it's just interesting
to note how they definitely change the
structure just a little bit on the
handset version just so they can fit it
into the three sort of three standard
tabs there and make it like it still
look nice yeah okay let's move on so you
should do a time check okay so the next
app is pocket and pocket is actually I
think it's called pocket formerly read
it later pocket is basically a it's a
saved list of articles so you know if
you're browsing you know an artists
espied and you don't want to read it
right now you just you know go off and
save it to pocket and they have you know
an intent that you can share too and all
those good things so this is a is the
kind of the main screen in Pocket that
lets you see the list of your saved
articles so you'll see that on the phone
they have a simple list with thumbnails
on the right now when you when you scale
it up to a seven inch tablet they have a
two column grid and if you turn it over
into landscape you'll see that there's a
three column grid and you'll notice that
it's it's completely different but it's
the same content right it's more like a
tile view rather than a simple you know
horizontal linear layout and then if you
look at the 10 inch tablet they
basically graduated into more of a quote
unquote magazine layout similar to how
Google Play client application lays out
the different tiles in the featured
sections so the interesting thing to me
is that you know they've done a lot of
work here to to tweak font sizes so
you'll notice that like the the text the
title sizes
on the ten inch tablet are slightly
larger than on the seven inch tablet and
then the fact that they have basically
implemented this layout three times you
know once is a list another is a grid
view which is probably a you know a
simplified version of the magazine
layout on the right but they also have
that kind of the magazine layout which
we don't have framework support for one
of the things I should know is they may
have cheated a little bit they may be
using webview and you know html5 and
css3 stuff to do the layout which is you
know it's perfectly awesome the only
issues that there's you know some minor
performance penalties well maybe not
minor but there are some performance
penalties involved but overall it looks
just just wonderful yeah so that's a
nutshell the other thing I wanted to
mention is that they kept the action bar
the same and this is you know totally
fine it's you don't necessarily have to
you know switch the action bar and make
it taller make things wider the
framework actually does all of those
things for you it'll you know make your
icons slightly wider the action bar
slightly taller I'm so it'll do all
those things for you in this case I
think that they've probably implemented
a custom action bar so it's not
happening there but note that the action
bar is pretty much the same across
tablet and phone in terms of a behavior
in rough proportions I think one of my
favorite things they've done on here as
well
sorry it's a you can see on the phone
and tablet they've prioritized that
search bring it out right at the top of
the content view so you can search and
filter whereas on the tablet they have
kind of demoted that so less important I
think it's under the the action overflow
there which I think is really
interesting I think it's it's it's
showing that they fought about how
someone's going to use this application
slightly differently on a tablet that
there's you know they have the same
content available but it's a different
representation they're kind of a super
like designing for a different use case
where someone might have more time and
might have being more of an explorative
mode yeah
any comments yes okay so let's move on
to belief the oh no there's TED talk
about that Adam yeah so the Ted app
hopefully some of you are familiar with
with the Ted Ted app and all the great
content video talks that they have so I
like this example just because it's
fairly simple like you know you don't
have to do anything crazy complicated in
order to support different form factors
and have it look nice and feel nice
still so if you look at the three
different form factors that were posted
up here you've got the the handset in
portrait mode where they have this sort
of big thumbnail at the top and then
three sub tabs down the bottom to show
the sort of different views related to
that video and then you move to Nexus 7
which looks fairly similar they've added
some extra whitespace um let's just zoom
in here a little bit they've added some
extra whitespace are notably around the
tabs as well which is interesting but
otherwise it's it's fairly similar extra
rights I slightly bumped up font size
and then if you move to the landscape
10-inch let me zoom across here you'll
notice that they've moved from the sort
of stacked stacked layout of their
fragments to two being side by side but
essentially it's the same fragments you
know you can clearly tell their views
reuse the same fragments there one
interesting thing for the sort of video
thumbnail here is they've moved the
title from being a sort of transparent
overload overlay to beneath the actual
video because there's more room and they
can really bring out the sort of nice
video thumbnails and allocating a little
bit more space for that guys you have
any comments I just wanted to mention
one thing about the overall I guess the
overall structure of the screen it
reminds me of the YouTube YouTube
playback screen on Android and I think
that's actually a good thing I think
that users you know when they buy their
Android device they pop open YouTube
they instantly become familiar we
is you know how it behaves and I'm
guessing if you rotate into landscape it
starts you know at full screens they're
very familiar with how it behaves you
know the the kind of the tab structure
at the bottom on the phone that lets you
switch between the different pieces of
detail information about the video and
then in in tablet they basically do
something again very similar to YouTube
they pop that over to the right and this
is almost like a natural you know way to
you know take up the new amount or to do
something with the new space that you
have but I think that just like that
added extra bit of similarity to the
YouTube app makes it instantly familiar
to users Nick anything else before we
move on actually they've done a great
job of playing with the spacing as well
I think you could see that they
definitely hinted the spacing when you
go from phone up to seven-inch to make
it just feel that much more comfortable
on that size device so it's the kind of
thing where you might have just tried
the phone layout one on the 7-inch
device and for hey that's good enough
but they've actually gone the extra mile
to say actually it feels a little bit
cramped or would benefit from a little
bit more spacing here so they've gone
the extra mile to really optimize this
for these for the different device sizes
which is great yeah it's worth noting as
well that they don't they don't have a
landscape layout for this particular
screen on handset devices actually I'm
not sure if they if they support if they
if they actually have landscape for any
of this their screens on handset but for
a video app especially for video details
screen like this I think that's that's
ok sometimes um you know because people
should expect that when they rotate the
the video will be playing full screens
that um there's not really enough room
to do much else there yeah sorry that's
Ted okay so let's move on to I believe
the last step so we're kind of cheating
here because this is an app that we all
worked on this is the Google i/o 2012
application so basically this app if you
attended the conference it lets you you
know see what what sessions are playing
lets you create a schedule a
personalized schedule it also syncs
across your different devices which
again is very important for a multi
device
you know user that has multiple devices
having a seamless sync across those so
what we've done here is basically you
know on phone there's there isn't that
much horizontal space so we have three
tabs for the different core pieces of
functionality that's a kind of the
interaction side where you interact with
other people on Google+ they're also
telling the conference the my schedule
or my agenda area and then the
exploration phase where you can look at
the map or you know take a look at
individual tracks so the interesting
thing that we've done here is we've
split it up from tabs to multiple panes
across tablets so in portrait actually
both of these devices 7-inch and 10-inch
device in portrait they would show this
kind of three column or two column
layout where two of the panes are
stacked in one column and then a
landscape they switch to a wider three
column layout one of the key differences
between the 7-inch and 10-inch layouts
here is that the margins here on a
7-inch are 16 dip and here on a on a
tablet that's 10 inches they're 32 dip
and that actually gives a little bit
more breathing room for the for the
content on this 10-inch device you'll
notice this on the next screen as well
once we get to it that this kind of adds
a sense of you know spacing and the
separation of the two pieces of content
or the in here the three different
pieces of content any thoughts guys
beautiful app out of a design this is
amazing uh wondering uh Truman well one
thing I forgot to mention is that you
can't see this in the screenshot but
these tabs on phone as you swipe across
them there's actually a sixteen dip
divider that has it's actually just
empty space that divider is the same
gray background as is on the tablets so
like in this area so if you have
multiple devices there's a subtle hint
that these are actually you know part of
the same screen so as you slide on a
phone like I said you see that grey
background giving you that again that
sense of separation yeah one last thing
one one thing I really like personally
is on the tablet layout the sort of
alignment of the headings of each of the
different fragments it just it just
makes the app feel really nice and Ezra
was saying it's got the sort of padding
the equal padding there between the
different sections here and also the
little ticker which came from what it's
called the what's what's agnya that but
what sun fragment it's just sort of the
alignment there looks really nice makes
everything look really consistent and
one thing that we haven't done here is
user Roboto thin or Roboto light which
we probably should have so in case you
want to you know make the titles stand
out even more get even more attention
and I'm not convinced that it's
necessary here but it could use a large
point size and Roboto thin to kind of
give an elegant header at each of these
panes okay so let's move on to the the
second screen in this app and this is
basically the the session detail screen
so once I get into a specific session
like in this case the session that Chris
and Ellie gave on Android apps in Google
Play where they announced the new
publisher console once I get into the
screen you know there's a bunch of
information that I might want to seem
bunch of actions that we want to take on
this session for example and we want to
add it or remove it from my schedule
share it with people see a map of it
things like that may want to +1 it up
here
and we want to see the list of speakers
you learn more about Chris or Elly and
then there's a few links at the bottom
so what we've done here is this is a
single screen on well the session detail
in the list of sessions which is a
previous screen this is a single screen
on phones
whereas on tablets it's combined into a
multi-pane layouts is kind of the very
common master detail layout that's used
in almost all of our system apps you'll
notice that in portrait the it's not
really visible here we kind of need
animations we don't have the fancy
technology to show this but in portrait
it's it's kind of a sliding screen so
that left pane collapses once you start
interacting with the right detailed pane
and then pressing the UP button slides
it in again or just you know actually
sliding on the screen and then in tablet
in 10-inch tablets on landscape we have
all that space available so we don't
need that kind of that collapsing
behavior so it's always visible any any
thoughts guys and other things we should
point out now I already like the
treatment on the 7-inch here where it's
not quite wide enough to you know have
the same displays you have on the 10
inch to have all that information
permanently on-screen so it's a nice
solution with the sliding in and out to
give you a lot of the benefits of having
both on screen I like the quick
interaction between swapping between
their current sessions rather than
having to do on the phone where you have
to keep on going up and down back up to
see the other adjacent schedules and one
minor thing which which I like is that
there's this sort of concept of links
related to a particular session so these
are so dynamic links related to a
session that fall below on the handset
and a mechanism and a nexus 7 version
but then if you go to the 10-inch
version in landscape you'll see they
sort of fall alongside the content
instead so just yet and that case a
great way to give a magic like a natural
margin point as well so the details
doesn't get too wide I think yep
one of the natural points here is is
really just about texts text length and
whitespace right you really want to
optimize for you know to minimize large
large swaths of white space where
there's nothing on-screen you don't want
to throw information into one of the
along one of the edges of the screen or
the corners and then like I said about
the line lengths you want to really
optimize around you know a certain
number of characters per line because
you know any larger and it's going to be
you know it's a little less easy to read
in terms of like you know you're I
having to jump to the next line and then
any smaller it's kind of like a
newspaper where if there's only like two
or three words per per line it becomes
really tedious you know reading a long
vertically long piece of text so really
that's one of the optimization points is
to make sure that the text itself is
very legible and that the white spaces
is adequately filled one last thing I
wanted to point out is just you know a
common thread across these you'll notice
that the green background maintains some
of the branding for the track so you'll
notice that the icon the action bar icon
here is colored green to indicate that
you're looking at Android and then the
green is persistent across the different
tablets all right so with that let's
move on to our last section since we
have four minutes left while we're on
time guys this is awesome and since we
have four minutes left let's jump into
Android design news so the first bit of
news and this is not really news sorry
for whiny people so this is actually an
article from colonel grachov who's one
of the engineers on one of our one of
googles apps one of Google's very
popular apps he wrote a series of
articles on responsive mobile design
they're they're more like I guess
developer focused but they do focus a
lot about you know the different
switching points the margin points as
Nick was alluding to and how you make
those decisions
and then basically you know how that
affects your different layouts on
tablets
I will caveat that this is a little over
a year old so some of the some of the
thinking is you know the older version
or the the predecessor of what our
current design thinking is but it's a
phenomenal intro to responsive mobile
design moving on Nick I think this is
yours
yeah this is a this is fantastic to see
that this is one of the applications
which we took a look at two weeks back
called glimmer which was an application
15 photos from Flickr and it doesn't say
good job to the developer pull book he's
taken taken two designs and implemented
them already you can see the change here
in the before and after of his first
screen so no longer is it just a plain
just login but he actually shows up some
content right from the beginning and it
and it looks really nice I think he's in
a wonderful job so good job Paul yeah
totally I will good job Nick as well for
inspiring the initial designs
next is the verge Nick you want to talk
about that at all yeah sure so and the
verge popular gadget and my go toon
gadget news site is just a holo redesign
so you can see here they stayed pretty
faithful to the the holo look and feel
while marrying it to their branding
quite successfully I feel so generally a
really nice job a few few issues with
the navigation in the application and
but they've done a good job and I'm also
really pleased to see them use the draw
navigation pattern pretty pretty
correctly so that's very good to see ya
next we have actionbarsherlock and this
is more focused towards developers but
actionbarsherlock is a library by the
very famous Jake Wharton it's a library
that lets you use the action bar not in
all of its glory on devices or that
don't really have a honeycomb Ice Cream
Sandwich yet for example gingerbread
devices and the latest version version
4.2 ads I believe it's preliminary
support for search view so if you've
been designing around search view
because you must support Gingerbread
this may be a good way to backport that
that view and I think that's it for this
week I think we're one minute early but
again thanks for tuning in and we hope
to see you next time where we will
actually be doing redesigns of video
player apps that are reviewed this
Friday I believe on the app clinic
thanks again as always I'm Roman Nurik
Adam Kosh Nick butcher
signing off see you guys later thanks
guys but
[Music]